[Music]
let's rock your body by Justin
Timberlake the hit song was produced and
co-written by Pharrell Williams and Chad
Hugo known professionally as The
Neptunes they're two of the most
successful producers of all time and
their sounds defined the 2000s The
Neptunes were just named to the
Songwriters Hall of Fame yesterday I
caught up with him not long after they
got the news at criteria recording
studios just outside Miami this is sort
of thing matter to you being in being in
the Hall of Fame yeah it's acknowledge
me I want to say thank you to everyone
who helped us achieve such a feat it is
a pretty cool club to be it though when
you're with like Irving Berlin and whoa
Burt Bacharach whoa he'll David and yeah
you know I still can't believe it for
the past 25 years Pharrell Williams and
Chad Hugo have been one of the most
successful producing and songwriting
teams in music helping score number-one
hits for Nellie Wednesday funny
and Snoop Dogg in the crib mom drop it
like it's hot drop it like it's hot how
would you describe what each of you
brings to this well he's a savant he's a
genius
yeah he's a genius and and no no I'm
just an aunt I'm just an aunt the last
three letters of that word
Pharrell has always been the frontman
chad is mostly silent partners but I
learned so much from this guy this guy
he's the one to me what did you like he
showed me like how to play the chords
that I really liked yeah you know he's
literally the guy that like can pick up
any instrument and play anything vocals
and lyrics and chords and yeah musical
arrangements this guy
Pirela and Chad were teenagers when they
met in school in Virginia you met in
beginning band class is that right yeah
and we like make music in his parents
house at a talent show they were spotted
by producer Teddy Riley who took them
under his wing what were the biggest
sort of turning points for you
super dog yes yeah that was a moment the
number-one rap song got The Neptunes
noticed when it was released in 1998
jay-z worked with them and I just want
to love you
soon other growers began to open we were
introduced to Justin by jay-z I guess
the craziest things they produce and
co-write much of NSYNC star Justin
Timberlake's debut solo album jay-z
introducing us to to Justin that's what
got us in the studio with Britney Spears
[Music]
Neptunes who wrote I'm a slave for you
help Britney escape her girl-next-door
image we didn't know that we were
creating a sound or starting anything we
just knew because we were influenced by
so many different things we knew we
needed to be just as different yeah and
polarizing and polarizing yeah I mean
all the stuff that we love was
polarizing we could not take that crazy
random what seemed like random at the
time opportunity and just sounded like
someone else The Neptunes are working
together again this week in Miami's
criteria recording studios with rising
rap star Megan the stallion stallion
illness meg Meg is short for machine
other major projects are rumored to be
in the works can you talk about what
you're working on at all no only because
I can you know we want to be respectful
I mean you've written so many songs do
you have any favorites I mean it changes
for me all the time doesn't yeah what is
it now mr. Mason is good but Pharrell
says his favorite songs are the ones
that give him a feeling I like when
something comes on and it feels
inherently different than anything that
came before it yeah ditto
please I told you savant just
unbelievable not every day you get four
Elway I'm saying mr. Mason is good this
is true but it goes back to that
interview you did with him the initial
one Apple yeah but what he said well you
just you drilled him you nailed him to
the wall on the issue of that humility
of him yes he's it's extreme he's so
mean the first thing he said when we
talked about the Songwriters he's like I
want to thank everybody else is it you
know it's he's always said it's not just
me it's not just us and we see that yeah
and you see it